foreign
Prince
[Applause]
well you knew LeBron was going to make
the play right look at all the green and
black jerseys as he drives collapses on
the king
and he finds one of his core gestures in
the corner
and Dennis Schroeder
ice water in the veins Schroeder
has gone three of four from distance
James comes up with his fourth assist
[Music]
and 1.4 to go the Wolves took their
final time out
the stare down by Schroeder
[Applause]
[Music]
and it's a foul on Anthony Davis
contesting
a foul on Anthony Davis on the shot by
Connolly in the short corner
on a three-point drive and that means
three free throws and Conley has not
been to the line tonight and they can't
challenge it
yep there's the contact right there
that's that's an easy call you're
protecting the player Conley is an 83
free-throw shooter he's had a monster
game tonight for the Timberwolves 20
points
six threes but his first free-throw
attempt coming up with a tenth of a
second left in the game they Trail by
three and a lot of icing going on at the
free-throw line Vanderbilt
this is Minnesota's first free-throw
attempt this half
oh my goodness that was a nervous Nelly
first free throw there by Conley and he
has two more to go
we love playing basketball this is what
you want
[Applause]
no timeouts
oh man that's pressure
that is absolute pressure and we've got
over time oh my goodness